hey what's up my name is Samuel lead I
did a video last week a property video
and got loads of amazing questions you
have questions comm and below next week
check out for the video and of course
don't forget to smash the like bone also
subscribe to the channel turn the
notification belt on that way when I do
my video next week answering your
questions you're gonna get a pink and
you're gonna see the video so let's see
what we got from the last week's and
great questions Jimbo Jimbo says hi son
don't have a question I'm going to sell
my house and move into you rented
accommodation smart good idea then we'll
use my equity of 250,000 pounds to
invest in property would you buy one
place cash and BRR and pour most money
out or would you buy lots of single
let's HMOs etc if you were made thanks
and I first want to say thanks in
advance
listen Jimbo it takes just as much
effort to buy one big property as it
does to buy lots as it did sorry I said
just to buy one small property so if
you're going to use that 250 grand
you're going to buy lots of single
that's it's going to be quite a process
and you're going to buy them a mess
around if you're advanced and you know
your stuff if it was me I would use that
250 per not invest into one property I'd
buy a piece of land build some houses
and then we pull my money out because
it's just as much effort if you just
start now and you've got tuned to 50
grams you might want to say I'll start
with 25 grand a little small property
get some lower experience get my
confidence up so it really depends on
what you're trying to achieve if I had
to new fifty grams one deal every time
have the helps next Zack Gregory great
videos and great enthusiasm
thanks my question is why rent where you
live if the rent would cost the same as
a mortgage then why not get a mortgage
instead you could then read our rooms
and claim seven thousand five hundred
tax-free yes you could you can even
change it over to abide to that later
down the line if you want you also
benefit from needing much lower deposit
in the first place not to mention
capital appreciation just wanted to hear
your thoughts on it
listen Zack you've clearly thought this
throat okay and you've clearly watched
my videos where I'm saying rent where
you live I rent where I live I'm
generally speaking as a prince of what
people think that they should buy their
own house and isn't it a great
investment and it's not because if you
buy somewhere to live it's not going to
make you any money it's actually go
humanik so my argument is use your
savings and your investment money to
actually invest don't buy stuff don't
buy a car and buy a house and buy a this
and buy that red stuff and pay for it
out of the investment money it makes
sense however I mean you've mentioned
the idea of buying somewhere you've put
on a smaller deposit correct and then
you could rent the rooms out listen if
you have really thought this through and
you're prepared to buy a house and
you're prepared to rent rooms out in
your home and you're thinking
strategically because most people when
they buy somewhere to live
they don't think strategically they
think I like this house but if you're
combining the two and the maths work
then fine buy a house live in it rent
the rooms out be strategic and then
switch it to buy-to-let later make maybe
maybe that's an OK plan okay but just
generally speaking what happens like
this house not at my house if I bought
this house number one I wouldn't want to
rent the rooms out because I want it to
be my house so I wouldn't want to do
that
number two the money I'd have to put
down to buy this house I'm much better
off renting it because I can't it's just
a commercial this I just car so I think
you're a switched-on guy I can tell from
the way you phrase the questions within
the I can tell you switched on guys so
for you I think if you do it
strategically rent the rooms out I
wouldn't condemn that but generally
speaking I think people need to get out
of the mindset just buying their house
to live in you know so hope that helps
Zak I'd love to know your thoughts on my
response so if you're watching comment
below and I hope you are watching alpha
moments
Simon a question for you that seems to
be slowing down my whole process is
there such a thing as trying to
overthink an entry into the property
market learn a lot from your channel and
other resources and wanting to create a
business that will utilize the findings
for a 10-year plan and possible exit at
that point but in trying to make sure I
have literally everything thought about
I'm slowing down the process am i
overthinking things yes you are
overthinking things you cannot figure
everything out it's impossible you can't
even have a 10-year plan get one month
plan and then go friggin make it happen
stop thinking I need to have a ten year
plan I need to figure it all out before
I do anything you are over thinking yes
s are 100 question for deal sourcing I
found a lot of info in your videos
thanks at the crash course good job
and online about both compliance and
financial side of things the one area
which seems to be unspoken off is how to
physically pack the deal usually an
email Excel spreadsheet PowerPoint or is
it something else thanks in advance yeah
so if I if I'm stacking the deal as in
packaging it I'll just put some
literature together it could be an Excel
spreadsheet it could be just points on
an email some pictures some market
research put that together and then
that's your little pack then that's like
your sales presenter that's like this is
the deal and this is my research and
there's no magic way to do it and also
you're gonna get better as you go on so
you're the first time you write down all
the info it's going to be separate maybe
maybe find someone else there's
packaging they're selling deals ask them
to look at their deals and then use
their template I mean always very happy
for you just copy my templates from
deals I've sold in the past but just
just just put the information down just
put it down
don't worry about should it be like this
or what format just put the information
down and put it out there home out good
job well done okay
Donita how do I go about converting a
three bed flats above a retail shop into
a HMO all three are double rooms
fire-safety HMO regs guidance on council
website I'm not very black-and-white
I've also tried to approach a HMO
officer to come around to guide me with
what they'd like changed but they
refused to send one many thanks they
should not do that bring them back bring
them back and say to the council and say
I'm turning listen to a HMO your website
is not clear I will pay
they're normally charged 75 to 100
pounds nor they'll come for free but
these guys are clearly not great people
I will pay please come because I don't
want to rent this out illegally I need
your that's what the counselor for they
need to give you the information and if
they don't take their name so are you
saying that you work something anybody
and you won't help me on this okay
what's your name please your full name
as would like to send a letter of
complaint like they need to give you the
information I've never had to happen
I've never had them not not not keeping
the information won't come out well and
you might have to pay you have to pay a
small thing alright last one last one if
a tenant moves in without signing
a ski contract will this make it easier
to evict them if it's baked no never
never never always need to contract if
you've got no contract you're gonna
really struggle to get them out because
you've got their grounds you need the
contract ASD hope you found that video
useful I hope you learned a lot don't
forget to comment your questions below
also if you enjoyed the video smash the
like button show some support and
subscribe turn the notification bells on
if you want to come to the property
investors crash course which is a
two-day property program it's very good
it's a very good program and you're
gonna have your mind blown and so many
doors are gonna open for you at the
crash course you can get your free
ticket on the hats there's a one-pound
booking fee but you can get your free
ticket right over here don't forget to
subscribe as well over here thanks so
much
book on the crash course subscribe I'll
see you next time
[Music]